قد لا تبدو المدينه هذه المزدحمه بالسكان
قادره على استيعاب المزيد من الناس ولا
سكانها انفسهم قادرين على دفع تكاليف
السكن فالاسر الفقيره هنا وخاصه للنازحه
اتخذت من هذه الدكاكين مسكنا لها بعد رفع
ملاك العقارات اجور الشقق السكنيه في تعز
الى اكثر من مئه في المئه
الدقون على قدر على قدر حالي اما الشقه
مقدرش يستاجر شقه ابدا نهائيا لان الوضع
اننا الاجارات ارتفعوا الاسعار وكل شيء
ارتفعوا احنا ما نقدرش
250 150 180 الايجار حق الشقق نجحنا
لعينين من احنا سبعه بل هذا الدكان والله
ان احنا ما يساحنه ولا حاجه من احنا سبعه
بنتي شباب بسبب ان احنا ما نقدر نستعجل
شقه ليست هذه الاسره وحدها من اضطرت للعيش
في مكان يفتقر لنافذه واحده بل هناك
العشرات من الاسر واجهه المصير ذاته بعد
ارتفاع اجور الشقق السكنيه الى 150 الف
ريال للشهر الواحد اوضع سويه صعبه تعيشها
هذه الاسر في اماكن اشبهوا بالسجون مع ترد
الوضع المعيشي وانقطاع الرواتب وتراجع فرص
العمل في البلد
معانا ما تخرج غير هذا الموتور يعني من
باريس قلم انه اكلنا شربنا كسوه العيد
مصاري في رمضان
على حسب الظروف حاولنا جاهدين على ان نقنن
هذه المساله وقلنا يجب ان يرفع
بالجانب المنطقي وهو 10% الى 20% اما ان
يرفع 200 الى 300% فهذا شيء غير مقبول
هكذا اذا بدا مسكن الاسر الفقيره في
المدينه هذه وهكذا بدا حالهم مع ارتفاع
اجور السكن امر دفع بعض الاسر الى مغادره
المدينه التي تفتقر الى اليات تنظم الاجور
بين المواطن وملاك العقارات
الى اكثر من مئه في المئه اذا ارتفعت اجور
العقارات والشقق السكنيه داخل محافظه تعز
وهو من عكس سلبا على الحياه المعيشيه
للمواطن اليمني لكن الجهات الحكوميه تحاول
جاهده الحد من هذه الاشكاليه هل سعيد
العربيه تعز